we don't have a myth of our arch we have
some history we might mythologize the
founding fathers we apologize our
revolution but there's not a myth in
that sense I say it's not an original
idea with me not out of modesty but to
point out that Longfellow one of the
most popular artists in the history of
America I mean he was at least as
popular as Steven Spielberg is today
Longfellow set out to create myths quite
consciously that's why he wrote the
midnight ride of Paul Revere he knew it
wasn't an accurate piece of history he
wanted to give us a myth his song of
hiawatha was an attempt to do that in
retrospect it isn't the way we went it
isn't exactly how we did it though
there's still a lot of people who love
those poems Whitman understood the
national spirit better and John Ford
understood it better could be you could
argue that WC handy understood it better
but it is an issue and we have a lot of
history in where we have so much history
because of the different ethnicities
that it's almost in a panic we boil it
down and reduce it to me it's a very
interesting watershed or dividing line
in this particular week of our history
that Barack Obama gave a speech in which
he tried to talk about the multiplicity
of his own ethnicity and his family he
said I have relatives who I'm staying
group uni I think one of his
brother-in-law's is Chinese his mom was
married to an Indonesian guys
grandmother's a white lady from Kansas
and that's a lot of history for some
people a plethora of history
in some ways would be simpler to be
polish country where most people are all
one religion for example their different
destinies and memory is a different
phenomenon for us than it might be for
the bengalis or the poles and you know
only thing I'm an expert on is the
sounds of words I'm not a historian I'm
not a cultural historian but I can dare
to observe that that's interesting that
multiplicity of memory and that perhaps
plethora of history as we're thinking
you